alors pas le l'euro celui là quoi mais
l'europe a en photo l'euro en vidéo ok
j'ai compris vannes pourries en trop
[Musique]
à
et salue les gens derrière les grands
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
moi encore je suis ravi de vous
retrouver comme à chaque fois pour une
nouvelle vidéo
si vous êtes nouveau sur cette chaîne
sachez que ici on parle de faire des
vidéos on parle de tournage on parle de
montage on parle de matos bref on parle
de plein de choses
et rassurez-vous même si cette vidéo
s'apparentent à quelque chose d'un petit
peu technique d'un petit peu réservé à
certaines grosses caméras détrompez-vous
en fait c'est accessible à pas mal de
gens et c'est pas si compliqué que ça
dans cette vidéo je vous expliquer ce
qu'est l'euro pourquoi on peut s'en
servir et à quoi ça peut servir
mais aussi comment le traiter avec votre
logiciel alors l'euro un petit peu comme
en photo c'est un format de fichier qui
se veut brut comme son nom l'indiqué et
non compressé en gros et je vais
simplifier on va récupérer toutes les
informations possibles que le capteur a
pu engranger sans compression ou du
moins avec peu de compression donc
beaucoup plus de détails dans la lumière
et de détails aussi dans les couleurs
des rohan vidéo il en existe plusieurs
sortes il ya le black magic raw par
exemple pour les caméras black magic il
ya le raid code pour les caméras aide et
il ya aussi le projet the rocket un
codec qui a été créé par apple perd les
images dont je vais me servir pour vous
montrer un petit peu comment ça se
traiter à quoi ça sert c'est du projet
seront donc comme je le disais l'euro
c'est un format qui va nous permettre de
récupérer un maximum d'infos d'avoir une
plage dynamique très étendu la plage
dynamique c'est les informations qu'on
peut avoir jusque dans les basses
lumières vous dans les hautes lumières
là pour le coup on va pouvoir tirer le
meilleur de notre capteur avoir des
basses lumières qui vont être riches en
informations et des hautes lumières qui
vont pas être cramé non plus l'autre
gros avantage
et ça c'est pas valable sur tout
l'hérault ni sur tous les appareils mais
c'est que la plupart du temps on peut
régler la balance des blancs en
post-production on peut également régler
la sensibilité iso aussi en
post-production et ça c'est plutôt cool
parce que dans une certaine mesure on va
pouvoir gérer notre exposition après
avoir shooté ce qui peut dans certains
cas être très très très très très utile
vous imaginez en fait les iso que vous
mettez à régler vous n'êtes pas sûr de
votre coup et tout sur le moment ou
alors voulait régler un peu à la va vite
parce qu'il ya des choses qui vont très
vite et bah ça vous pouvez leur régler
après coup sûr votre logiciel sur final
cut sur première sur davinci bref c'est
trop bien c'est hyper pratique
idem pour la balance des blancs on peut
toujours récupérer une balance des
blancs un petit peu approximatif sur des
formats compressés là c'est pas de la
récupération c'est tout simplement on va
pouvoir régler la balance des blancs
après avoir shooté et ça ça aussi c'est
quand même plutôt pratique alors vous
allez me dire mais pourquoi tous les
appareils ne propose-t-il pas du rau
pourquoi on ne foutent pas tous en gros
ça serait tellement pratique ça serait
tellement pratique il ya quand même des
petits points négatifs au fait
d'utiliser dur on est le plus gros point
négatif là dessus c'est comme vous vous
en doutez on a énormément d'informations
dans les fichiers qu'on récupère en raw
et ben forcément ça va prendre
énormément de place aussi pour vous
donner une idée en pro réseau en 4k en
pleine résolution et ben un fichier de
dix minutes pèse environ 90 giga donc
c'est quand même gaillard après moi
j'utilise le projet zorro du z 6 sur un
atom hausse et il ya un projet hydro hq
qui va être le plus défini il ya aussi
un progrès euros normal qui va être
beaucoup moins drôle alors pourquoi au
début je disais que l'euro n'est pas
forcément l'apanage des grosses caméras
type raid et bien c'est tout simplement
que sur mon êtes si cela le premier du
nom avec un atom hausse en
enregistrement externe j'arrive à avoir
du rau et ça c'est quand même hyper
pratique pour certaines productions
là par exemple c'est pas shooter en
euros parce qu'il y en a pas l'utilité
j'ai le contrôle sur la lumière je peux
faire un petit peu ce que je veux mais
pour certaines productions que je veux
de haute qualité
oui je shoote en euros pour avoir
beaucoup plus de flexibilité à
l'étalonnage et après au montage et pour
être un petit peu sûr de mon coup en
gros l'euro pour moi ça me permet
d'assurer mes arrières et d'être sûr que
tout sera correctement exposée est
talonné on va donc passer dans final cut
on va les voir tout de suite comment se
comporte ce euros une fois qu'on l'a
importée alors ce que vous pouvez voir
ici c'est que on a dans les vignes est
quelque chose de très très très lumineux
limite crâne est alors dans le pré
visualiseur on a quelque chose de à peu
près correct de très saturé certes mais
d'à peu près correct c'est tout
simplement parce que là on est sur un
projet en vrac 709 on n'a pas créé un
projet en wide gamut ce qui est possible
sur final cut un métier plutôt à
destination des formats hdr donc des
choses que moi au quotidien j'ai pas
forcément l'utilité puisque mes vidéos
elles sont destinées
la plupart du temps à internet aux
réseaux sociaux donc au final je préfère
monter en règle 709 ce qui me laisse
quand même énormément de latitude donc
la première chose qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va sélectionner tous nos plans ici
en proposeront qu'on va aller dans
l'inspecteur et qu'on va utiliser une
lutte de conversion de roover du log qui
est quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
facile et beaucoup plus simple à traiter
à est talonné par la suite alors vous
avez vu ici on a deux bases le lob de
kanon de dj de nikon de panasonic 2 sony
alors c'est ça qui est cool dans l'euro
c'est qu'on va pouvoir choisir son
espace colorimétrique ici en pouvoir
choisir celui qu'on veut quelle que soit
la caméra qu'on a utilisées moi j'ai
plus l'habitude avec le s log donc on va
prendre ici le s l'octroi avec un gamut
signer et boum
on se retrouve avec des fichiers qui
ressemble trait pour trait a dû s blog
sauf qu'il est en 12 bits et qu'on a une
latitude et une plage et des couleurs de
malades puisqu'on était en rond au
départ donc tout simplement maintenant
ce que je vais faire c'est que je vais
aller chercher mes plans ici voilà et
que je vais les étalonner comme je ferai
sur du lobe tout simplement leur soit je
peux utiliser une lutte de conversion
mais ça j'aime pas trop je préfère le
faire à la main je vais tout simplement
aller dans ici dans ma roue de couleur
baisser les ombres et vous pouvez voir
que par exemple ici j'aimerais bien les
baisser un peu plus mais je suis à 0 et
banon quand y'en a plus y'en a encore si
je baisse encore voyez pas que je baisse
la mais pourtant je fais glisser je peux
encore aller très très loin et c'est là
où on est sur quelque chose de super
cool avec l'euro c'est qu'on peut aller
très très loin dans
l'exposition notamment ici mon plan
était légèrement surexposé c'est pas
grave j'ai de la marge
il ya de l'info dans les hautes lumières
il ya des infos dans les basses lumières
donc c'est parfait ici je suis plutôt
bien je ne sais pas si je vais pas
remonter un petit peu légèrement les
hautes lumières voilà on est pas mal on
a recréé le contraste on va pouvoir
remonter un petit peu la saturation
également envoyé que les teintes de peau
sont vraiment vraiment très sympa
pourrait très rapidement faire une
petite manip de colo on va aller dans
les courbes de couleur on va faire un
truc très simple qui marche pas
forcément pour tous mais qui marchent
souvent c'est faire une petite courbe en
s avec les trois couleurs rouge vert et
bleu alors au début ça fait un truc très
bizarre vous allez voir mais après c'est
beaucoup mieux sommes là et pour finir
le bleu hop hop
et là on a quelque chose de plutôt pas
mal s'est fait très rapidement pour
aller beaucoup plus loin on peut
l'utiliser des luttes si vous avez
l'habitude d'utiliser des luttes aussi
hélas par exemple si je fais un
avant/après avant après c'est pas dégueu
c'est pas des gorilles mon plan up et
alors ce que vous pouvez voir aussi
c'est que malgré la lourdeur des
fichiers comme le propose c'est le codec
qu'utilise final cut pour lire la
timeline ça reste très très souple et
très rapide au niveau calcul c'est pas
un codec qui va prendre un temps énorme
à être traité avait vu là j'ai appliqué
mais correction colorimétrique et ça
c'est fait quasi instantanément le rendu
est du coup bah on a quelque chose de
vachement facile à monter et à étalonner
et a travaillé tout simplement là dessus
mais on n'a pas encore fini avec ce
fameux rond on a encore plein de choses
à se dire
voilà grosso modo vous avez vu un petit
peu ce qu'on peut faire avec c'est quand
même plutôt cool c'est vraiment un codec
que moi j'aime beaucoup utilisé bien
entendu je vais pas aller m'amuser a
ajouté un mariage avec ça parce que
forcément les fichiers seront beaucoup
trop groupe je m'en servir par exemple
sur du clip je vais m'en servir sur des
prods où j'ai des clients qui veulent un
résultat vraiment très étalonner et
quelque chose de vraiment poussé mais
pour le quotidien on va dire pour un
petit film qu'au repos pour un mariage
c'est pas forcément le codec que je vais
utiliser là je préférais shooter en
interne même si j'ai un moins
d'informations dans le signal donc si
vous avez un appareil photo ou une
caméra qui en externe permet
d'enregistrer en enrobé franchement je
pense que ça vaut le coup d'aller
essayer un petit peu de voir ce que ça
donne avec un enregistreur type atomos
par exemple parce que vous pourriez
avoir des surprises et que ça pourrait
être quand même vachement sympa à tester
c'est pas forcément 20 mètres pour tous
je vous mets la liste en descriptions
des caméras qui permettent de shooter en
pro réseau donc allé voir si la vôtre le
père mais ça peut être intéressant
et puis n'oubliez pas que toutes les
fonctionnalités du rhô ne sont pas
présentes surtout plus caméra par
exemple sur 26 pour le moment il n'y a
pas encore la possibilité de gérer les
iso et la balance des blancs en poste ni
koné atomos travaille dessus mais pour
l'instant ce n'est pas possible mais
malgré ça le signal est quand même
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment très
très très intéressant même sur des
résolutions en dessous de la 4k et ça je
pense que c'est utile de le savoir et
d'ailleurs si vous pensez que c'est
utile de le savoir vous aussi vous
pouvez mettre le traditionnel coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui situe
juste en dessous de cette vidéo pouvez
vous abonner
si c'est pas déjà fait les amis et puis
moi je vous dis rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
et oui je vous ferai une vidéo sur le z
6-2 et le z7 2 avec lesquels j'ai shooté
ses superbes images j'espère d'ailleurs
que vous avez vu le documentaire de
nikon sur la sortie de z 6 ou 7 6 2
puisqu'il y avait votre serviteur à
l'intérieur et que j'en suis assez
content ma foi c'était plutôt
sympathique à faire mais je vous
raconterai tout ça dans une prochaine
vidéo